yes guys climate change correspondent
Hannah Thomas Peter just a warning her
report does contain some flash
photography ExxonMobil is one of the
world's largest and most powerful oil
and gas corporations like other fossil
fuel companies it has long been accused
of understanding decades ago what its
product would do to the planet but
continuing to expand to profit and to
question the science of global warming
it's against that backdrop that the
company finds itself on trial in New
York for misleading investors about
climate change this case is being
brought by New York State's Attorney
General who's accusing Exxon of telling
investors that it had priced in the risk
associated with increasing regulations
to combat climate change but in fact was
doing nothing of the sort
effectively the Attorney General is
accusing Exxon of cooking its books to
artificially boost the value of its
company and make it cheaper to pollute
some are comparing this trial to the
beginning of the legal onslaught against
big tobacco excise disclosures
we're not talking how to run scissors
it was is always free business practices
but Exxon's lead lawyer has denied all
wrongdoing and accused new york state of
a politically motivated which money
power and politics are all under
scrutiny here even Rex Tillerson former
CEO of Exxon and former Secretary of
State to Donald Trump is expected to
testify the trial could last for three
weeks if the state of New York is
successful Exxon could pay over a
billion dollars in damages and suffer
untold damage to its reputation Hanna
Thomas Peter sky news at the New York
Supreme Court